So speaking of Happiness bias data
collection and anecdotes you have to
how's that for a
transition you have to you have to tell
uh me the story of the the call you made
the customer service call you made to
demonstrate a point um about weight
times yeah this is very early in the
history of Amazon and uh we were going
over a weekly Business review and a set
of documents and I have I have a saying
which is when the data and the anecdotes
disagree the anecdotes are usually right
and and it doesn't mean you just
slavishly go follow the anecdotes then
it means you go examine the data because
the DAT and it's usually not the data is
being um misol it's usually that you're
not measuring the right thing and so you
know if you have a bunch of customers
complaining about something
and at the same time you know your
metrics look like why they shouldn't be
complaining um you should doubt the
metrics and an early uh example of this
was we had metrics that showed that our
customers were waiting I think less than
I don't know 60 seconds when they called
a 1 1800 number to get you know phone
customer service the weit time was
supposed to be less than 60 seconds and
but we had lot of complaints that it was
longer than that and anecdotally it
seemed longer than that like you know I
would call customer service myself and
so one day we're in a meeting we're
going through the wbr and the weekly
Business review and we get to this
metric in the deck and the guy who leads
customer service is to fit in the metric
and I said okay let's
call and I picked up the phone and I
dialed the 1800 number and called C
customer service and we just waited in
silence for what did it turn out to be
like oh really long more than 10 minutes
I think oh wow I mean it was it was many
minutes and so you know it dramatically
made the point that something was wrong
with the data collection we weren't
measuring the right thing and and that
you know set off a whole chain of events
where we started measuring it right and
that's an example by the way of of Truth
telling is like that's an uncomfortable
thing to do yeah but it's but you have
to seek truth even when it's
uncomfortable and you have to get
people's attention and they have to buy
into it and they have to get energized
around really fixing
things